[Music]
it takes two studios to deal with ego of
Michael pen before time began there was
the cube that's not what the Bible says
dispute is a racist the Sun Goes Down
completely between the time this bogey
chopper is 5 miles out and when it
arrives at the base this car drove
itself on the lot and no one noticed
Bernie Mac is dead and that sucks
I get the bumblebee as Sam's guardian
sent ahead by the Autobots to protect
him but how would he have done that if
Sam hadn't just happened to be buying a
car at this point is like the only real
lead we have so far is this sound that
face had no cameras and how does the
military not of a satellite pointed at
this super important base they can go
pull images from dealing with a very
effective weapon system that we had not
come across before the US government
would never reveal this kind of
information to the public this maybe it
was all too well that the father she
doesn't know could be hurt missing or
killed whatever those things mean well
Ariel is probably busy if you tried mer
man it's a lake public property just
because it's a lake doesn't mean it's
public property sure I'm glad we get to
see Sam's football try out or none of
this woody banter would have made any
sense when bumblebee transforms into a
robot what happens to the biatch air
freshener there's no way this girl has
been in the same school with Sam for 10
years and doesn't know who he is and
that he's in the same class with her I
know bumblebee is the one making the car
breakdown but why the hell was Sam on
this dirt road in the first place it
leads to a cliff no sins found in this
scene Mikaela goes from trying to help
Sam fix his car to bailing and leaving
him there in the span of about three
seconds passenger door left open but
then mysteriously closed in the next
shot this is way too smart fra Iranian
scientist Wow this movie is really very
racist the stereo gets on Air Force One
Halligan oncoming flight attendant
somehow completely misses transformer
lurking behind this dude's chair can you
wrangle me up some ding-dongs darlin ha
ha George Bush was stupid also this
robot is trying to sneak down into the
cargo area to hack the network but is
able to sneak into the planes main cabin
before it takes off why didn't you just
go ahead and go on down to the cargo
area in the first place so wait the best
way for the Decepticons to find out
about Project Iceman was to sneak aboard
Air Force One and hack its computers
sneaky robot alien insults the audience
a second time by leaving Air Force One
in plain view with
being seen these dogs only get upset
when they get noticed around cylinders
the number one defense against angry
dogs that just destroyed a brick wall
chasing after you the only countries are
this kind of capability Russia North
Korea maybe China okay so now according
to this movie North Korea is as much of
a threat as or China when it comes to
hacking North Korea doubling its naval
activity or what is known in North Korea
as a Tuesday so far the Decepticons have
had reasons for showing up in certain
places the Scorpion shows up were pretty
much no reason at all except that there
hasn't been a good action scene since
the beginning of the movie these highly
trained soldiers are blind - I don't
know what he's saying but it's not what
we're here no let's not inform the
government there might be one person who
can hack the code let's just put it on
this possibly traceable disk and sneak
out to go find the guy also they're
really super impossible to break code
it's on a two gigabyte memory card the
popular hot girls would never be caught
dead eating together at Burger King
why does bumblebee do nothing and wait
while Sam gets terrorized by the cop
robot instead of rescuing him right away
daytime to nighttime in mere seconds for
the second time in the movie so
bumblebee fucked up this police car
robot but we were stuck watching comedy
relief robot get his ass kicked my Sam
Dewalt so tough it'll cut through a
transform I don't understand the talk
through the radio thing I mean is he
finding all these clips on actual radio
stations live because what station is
playing John Wayne quotes and he's able
to just use any old clip then why is it
so much harder apparently for him to
just speak like a regular robot
what the Autobots decide to crash-land
on earth in the most whole way possible
well the director of transformers just
slapped the guy who directed Armageddon
so all the Autobots just chose to be the
first car they saw the only reason
Optimus Prime is a semi is because one
just happened to drive by Wow even alien
robots know how to cash in on a good
product placement opportunity there's a
robot outside my room can I have a glass
of water as far as I'm concerned Optimus
Prime's lips can go suck on the Batsuit
nipples there's vocal process or damage
to work so these alien robots can
transform into any shape they want but
they can't fix a king vocal processor
hello does Optimus Prime know about any
of these events why did the police let
this guy change his shirt between his
arrest in his interrogation Anthony
Anderson starts eating the plate of
doughnuts at 10:45 and finishes the
plate at 10:45 I don't know there's
totally still a donut on that plate once
again no one notices large machines just
hanging around and playing view this guy
takes out the power but then the power
is all back on
well here's John Turturro not doing the
right thing you in the training bra that
statement is extra creepy a few seconds
later when he does this season criminal
knows a hot awesome magnet weapon only
impacts guns and no other metal things
like cufflinks watches badges cars or
other transformers don't worry Optimus
Prime was using his soft legs to try and
catch Sam on the cable this is the image
from Mars here's the image your special
ops team was able to retrieve from the
base attack no the image from the base
attack looked like this you guys just
photoshopped this later in the movie so
that the tool images would look a lot
more similar but I've seen goodness in
them
man Optimus Prime is really optimistic
about humans after learning about us on
the world wide web he must have stayed
away from the YouTube comments wants to
use the Q transform human technology to
take over the youth this plan is bull
and Megatron landed thousands of years
ago what technology was he gonna use
from back then
you guys know where it is don't you
follow me well we might as well just
show you every piece of classified
information that we have I mean why not
you did buy that one car that turned out
to be a transformer President Hoover had
the dam built around Titus energy and
also control floods provide irrigation
water and produce hydroelectric power
using the Colorado River did Starscream
have to wait for takeoff clearance from
the tower because I don't think they
just let fighter jets take off without
having some idea who's flying in where
it's going
wouldn't be smarter if one or even all
of the Autobots chose this important
moment to turn into a plane or a
helicopter instead of the same first car
they saw after arriving on earth they
even say we're autonomous robots
Autobots for short meaning the OTO in
their name has nothing to do with the
fact that they turn into cars
Autobots learned English by studying the
World Wide Web
Megatron learned English from being
stuck in ice for thousands of years it's
okay that all these people died because
they worked with the government Michael
Bay rips off the spin around 360 during
a shoot out shot from bad boys too and
people make fun of JJ Abrams for lens
flare guess let's put the fate of the
entire world in the hands of a horny
awkward teenager because you can't leave
your men alone without you I guess this
product placement opportunity was just
too extreme for the other soft drink
brands why does the Allspark only create
evil transformers and not good ones
after 20 minutes of giant alien robots
fighting in the street how are there any
pedestrians left to be running away when
Optimus and Megatron halt your fighter
not defeat magic whom I need to thank
for waiting patiently right now while I
give you important instructions you must
push the cube into my chest the
Laurentian abyss is seven miles while
sea level deepest place on our planet um
no that's not any more scientifically
accurate than saying there's no gravity
in space
oh yeah he's married with a new baby
remember what it felt like that was
going to be important somehow why are
all these Autobots just watching Sam and
Mikaela make out
[Music]
is it fear or courage that compels you
mr. Anderson